okay so i have to start with you because
i felt like
you gave us all a moment in this movie
that just summed up the last year and a
half
so perfectly and i have to say thank you
for it oh no
the moment when you're trying to get
back into your suit
and it's just a little too tight
still fits yeah yeah yeah
i you know we shot that pre-pandemic too
i gotta say i was not
ready for it to have the resonance that
it had
but i clearly have been eating donuts
since way before
we've all been locked inside um but yeah
this has been a tough year for uh
for jeans everywhere and are fitting it
for waistlines everywhere yes
exactly um how does it feel though to
finally get this movie out there i mean
i came to the set of this movie
david and i think it was yeah we
august of 2019 yeah i feel like i you
know it's funny to talk to the press now
again
and to feel like i don't even you know
ask me questions and i i don't really
remember like
it's been like two years right since we
shot the movie since we were in it and
so and you know this
year and a half has been so
extraordinarily strange
for all of us that it's like it almost
feels like my mind is
you know what was life like before that
i'm really excited for people to see it
i'm really excited for the movie to get
out there i'm also just really excited
for a big old marvel movie
to be in cinemas and for us to go to the
cinema i've been
a couple times already and then this
movie's perfect because it's so
big it deserves to be on the screen the
action
you can really only absorb when you're
in a dark room with a huge screen and so
yeah i'm just really i think it's a
beautiful
gift to to the world at this time
i'm really excited for that it's being
being seen this way
at some point we all have to choose
[Music]
between what the world wants you to be
who you are
well let me just say um y'all did the
damn thing and so that's layman's terms
it's thank you i like that but you were
so right he gave me
everything i needed from a marvel movie
funny
action big it's got heart all of those
things
that you love now i want to ask you
about the action for a second because
you had quite an
action moment hanging off the side of
that plane i felt like i was watching
tom cruise sir i said wait a minute
what's up we're doing
i'm not here no man i am the opposite of
tom cruise man
i have the op that is a fake plane and a
fake window and a lot of cgi
i am not on the real helicopter i got to
tell you i mean the stunts are
unbelievable in this movie and the
guys who do those things and the girls
who do those things are
unbelievably talented athletes and
dancers sort of a combination of this
skill
that i do not possess hardly an ounce of
so
they'd plug me in and i would do various
things but in general
you know it's brutal i'm i'm in my mid
40s i mean my knees
are in my lower back are not meant to do
these things anymore
family back together again
you got fat
there's about like four guys that make
up red guardian of which i am
the face of uh but these guys
you know a lot of the fight guys a lot
of the guys who are doing this big stuff
are are these other guys who are amazing
as well and who helped create the
character because
i could not do what he does and it's
it's incredible
i'm in awe of them this isn't your first
time doing action so how does like
marvel action compare to you know what
you've done before
it is the ferrari of action and
it is feels like getting run over by a
ferrari
because it's so painful i mean it's
truly like a different
level of action we do action on stranger
things and elbow different projects that
did but
not like this uh not like this
these guys really are working on a
different level
now david i've talked to a couple of
your stranger things co-stars
and of course always trying to get
little nuggets about season four
good luck good luck bring it on right
what can we expect and has
this experience like with black widow or
training or whatever you did kind of
help shape
you know what we look forward to um
next season from you in stranger things
well first of all this season
i just love it it's i say this about a
lot
but it's my favorite season i think the
scripts get better the show gets bigger
in a certain way
but it also gets more fun there's some
fun stuff that we're doing this season
but also it's the
heaviest dramatic stuff i've ever had to
do we get to see a lot of
hopper at his most vulnerable um
we're gonna reveal a lot of backstory
points that we've only hinted at in
boxes in his attic um we're gonna see a
lot of these different
threads and also we get to see a rebirth
of him
you know he had been in season three
sort of this guy who's struggling with
his teenage daughter and sort of trapped
in this
world of his own darkness in a certain
way
and and now we get to see him
[Music]
re-emerge as a different human being and
in that way he has his vulnerability to
him and also this brutality that he
needs to
survive russia we get to see this whole
other side of him
it's some of my favorite stuff and
there's one thing in it that plays very
big in this season
that i've known since the first frame of
the first season
and we me and the duffers would sit
around and speculate on
who wouldn't this be cool the minute we
started shooting
and we never thought we'd even get a
second season and then we get to do it
in this season
and it's so satisfying to have had an
idea
five years prior and to go like oh this
is a season when we're gonna let out
this secret that we were like
we were using just as a subtle thing to
inform something
we're gonna like lay it out finally and
it's
it's really cool yeah okay so stranger
things fans go back and binge
out go back and watch this
[Laughter]
now listen i know we've all been been
shut down for like a year and a half and
and you were saying to your radio back
out in the world but david you kind of
did a lot during the pan break
and i just referenced that with because
i really loved your instagram post
to your real life wife and your
on-screen
wife uh rachel you got married like
scarlett during the pandemic y'all know
what's in with
water with y'all black widow folks your
black widow family getting married
during the pandemic
but how'd you luck out with such amazing
women on and off screen in your life
what are you doing right
i don't know i have no idea i have no
idea i don't deserve it
i haven't figured out i'm just always
been
drawn to really you know sort of
fascinating
intelligent fierce women and i was very
lucky
to work with rachel weiss who i think is
just one of the most talented people out
there
truly like one of the greatest actresses
of her generation one of the biggest
movie stars of her generation
and just a lovely human being but so
generous and so fun to work with and
of course like my wife who is a you know
extraordinarily brilliant
artist and human being and who you know
i really am so lucky to be a partner
too and with yeah i've really been very
lucky and i've
had a surprisingly nice
pandemic amidst everything i mean in
spite of everything i've managed to
you know to get married to shoot another
movie it's been
i've been extraordinarily fortunate